what's up ladies and gentlemen how you
doing today before we get started there
are a few announcements that I want to
make for those of you that entered the
giveaway for the world of Ice and Fire
book and the Game of Thrones trivia game
those two winners will be announced in
the very next video that I release I
have everything packaged up already and
ready to ship out along with the prizes
for those of you that won the Twitter
contest that I held that way I can just
mail everything out at the same time
after I get the addresses from the two
of you that won this most recent
giveaway and I want to thank all of you
that have participated also I finally
decided to make a patreon account which
you can find the link for that down in
the description a patreon account is
basically a support system for this
channel that allows any of you to donate
money if you choose to do so even if no
one donates it's not going to affect the
way that I upload videos to this channel
but any money that does go toward the
channel I will invest that money right
back into it I will be able to buy
better equipment so that I can produce
better videos whether that be
microphones or editing software or a
computer etc anyone that does pledge to
my patreon will also get credited in the
videos and they will also get more
content that I will be uploading over on
the patreon I will be releasing
exclusive videos over there I got some
big plans for this channel so for any of
you that do decide to pledge I really
appreciate that and if you can't afford
it
then I completely understand I never
expect anyone to just give me money so
don't worry about that
but enough of that [ __ ] let's get into
today's video in this video I want to
talk about Varys the master of
whisperers the collector of Secrets
who's almost like the three-eyed Raven
in a sense how the three-eyed Raven has
a network of weirwood trees to gather
information Varys has a network of
little birds that stretch across
multiple continents this man is shrouded
in mystery and with his large network of
spies he has obtained knowledge about
almost everyone and everything that goes
on into Seven Kingdoms now we don't know
a whole lot about Varys or is through
intentions and motives but one thing
that does seem to be pretty clear at
this point at least in the television
series is that he is a strong supporter
of the Targaryen
and he is on a quest for the restoration
of the realm and as of right now varus
has aligned himself with Daenerys
Targaryen who he believes can rule the
way that it was meant to be or at least
a way that he thinks it was meant to be
but there is someone else various is
about to cross paths with who also has
the blood of a dragon and that person is
Jon Snow who will play a pivotal role in
the restoration of Westeros the only
thing is not too many people know
exactly how important Jon Snow is at
this point but I think Varys might or at
least know who Jon's true parents are
the truth about Jon Snow's parents has
been arguably the biggest theory in the
entire story and for good reason and I
do know that there are a lot of people
out there that do not believe Jon's
parents are Rhaegar and Lyanna and if
you want to believe that for the books
then go right ahead but in the
television show they've made it very
clear who Jon's parents are and ever
since the Tower of joy scene happened
during season six I think all of us have
been wanting to know how jon is going to
find out the truth something he has
wanted to know his entire life and I
think most people believe that bran is
going to be the one to tell Jon what he
saw in his vision that day or maybe even
how and read because he was there with
Ned and he did return home with the
knowledge that Ned left the tower that
day with a baby boy or maybe even seeing
well totally we'll find this out at the
Citadel maybe he's going to stumble
across a book or certificate that
recorded the birth of John or even the
marriage of Liana and Rhaegar but I
think Varys being the one to reveal this
information is just as likely as any of
the other ones there has to be more
people out there that assume John is not
med Sun it's very hard to believe that
the Honorable Ned Stark would break his
vows and people have to be thinking it's
one hell of a coincidence that when Ned
went to find his sister he came back
with a child instead and I wouldn't be
surprised if Varys did some
investigating of his own using his
little birds or someone else as his lead
detectives Varys was on the small
Council for the Mad King who is Rhaegar
Targaryen father Varys was the mad Kings
master of whisperers he was the mad
spy master and intelligence agent Varys
knew the Mad King did not trust his son
Rhaegar and he also knew that Rhaegar
and Lyanna had ran off together so I
think it's very likely that Varys used
his spy network to find out exactly what
the hell was going on I don't know I
think that's too hard to believe Varys
was right in the thick of things when
all of these major events took place
that eventually led to the story we know
it as today in the game of Thrones
series so I could easily see Varys
obtaining the information about Rhaegar
and Lyanna affair and ultimately the
child that they had together one
interesting thing to note that could
just be a coincidence but considering
how much foreshadowing there is in a
series this could mean something but the
very first episode Varys appeared in was
season 1 episode 3 which was titled Lord
snow personally I think that's a pretty
interesting thing to know but there are
many theories out there about how Jon
Snow's going to find out about his
parents and I think Varys having this
knowledge is a nice addition to that
list John would surely believe bran if
he told him what he saw that day but
that doesn't mean the rest of the realm
is going to believe what brain says and
if Sam doesn't find something at the
Citadel then I think Varys could be the
one to provide some concrete evidence to
prove that John is actually a Targaryen
people already assumed that Littlefinger
may know something about this in
considering Varys obtains information
and has a very curious mind similar to
little fingers plus Varys is close
relationship with the Targaryens during
the time of John's birth I think he is a
likely candidate as well and there's one
other thing to mention I believe it was
in the season six history and lore bonus
features of the blue way where Varys
says that he has had access to papers
that contain explosive secrets there was
one major event that comes to my mind
when I think of that you'd be the judge
comment below and tell me what you think
do you think it's possible that Varys
knows this secret and will Varys be one
of the characters to reveal this and
help prove this let me know your opinion
I also want to give a quick shout out to
the two generous people that were so
kind to make pledges to my patreon
account already cows fukken chickens
made the first and biggest pledge so far
I cannot thank you enough Kyle I really
appreciate that
also want to shout out Britt who also
made a pledge thanks Brad you've always
been very supportive of the channel
thanks for watching everyone have a good
day and I'll see you down in the comment
section bye